hey this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning about article 4 of
the u.s constitution article 4 lays out
the nuts and bolts of how federalism the
system of shared governance between
states and the federal government works
in practice article 4 has four sections
the first two the full faith and credit
clause and the privileges and immunities
clause
talk about how states will treat each
other's citizens as well as they treat
the citizens of their own states then
the third section is an admissions
clause discussing how new states will be
added to the union and the fourth
section is the guarantee clause which
guarantees every state in the union a
republican form of government to learn
more about article 4 i sought out the
help of two experts aaron hawley is an
associate professor of law at the
university of missouri her scholarship
focuses on the federal courts and she
teaches constitutional litigation tax
policy and agricultural law professor
gabriel chin is the director of clinical
legal education at the uc davis school
of law he's a teacher and scholar of
immigration law criminal procedure and
race and law so professor holly can you
take us a little bit through why the
framers included article for what was
its purpose
the founders of the constitution were
very concerned that the federal
government be one of limited powers and
because of that they saw the states
as having an active and critical role in
placing a check
on the federal government so we've got
the three branches and their own checks
and balances and then we've got the
federal government and the state
government
also playing a role in checking and
balancing each other they wanted to
establish a strong central government
but also to ensure that it didn't have
too much power and the states were
critical to this effort
also they very much wanted the states to
act collectively not individually
as you'll recall the states had not been
doing so well under the loose articles
of the confederation they'd sort of been
going it alone on critical issues like
trade and defense as to the detriment of
the union so article 4 is also sort of
key to making sure that the states act
sort of as a unified whole rather than
than going it alone it's one country
made up of diverse states
and
if you uh prefer the way things are done
in nevada
uh you can move there and if you think
that some other state has a better set
of answers to uh to the problems of
modern life
you can move
what the full faith and credit clause
and the privileges and immunities clause
are designed to do is to facilitate
transactions to facilitate moving to
facilitate
uh
communications and commerce and trade
and travel among the states
but that doesn't mean that what's going
on in each of the states can't be very
very different
we often think of checks and balances as
being something that was designed to be
kind of horizontal that the legislature
and
the executive branch and the judicial
branch kind of all at the same level
checking each other but there's also
kind of this vertical checks and
balances happening too between the power
of the federal government the power of
the states and the power of the local
governments
absolutely so we've got the the you know
three branches and their checks and
balances but we also have a strong
central government uh that's checked in
large part by strong uh independent
sovereign governments in each of the 50
states and these states traditionally
have what are known as police powers so
they have a lot of inherent authority to
govern uh the people in those states um
subject to federal law uh but it really
does sort of place a check on uh federal
authority and i think this is precisely
what the framers wanted because they did
want a strong government but they also
were very much of the view that states
were important that their own states
were important and they didn't want to
lose that
in the new
new constitution and new federal
government
there are four sections in article four
and
the first section deals with full faith
and credit it says full faith and credit
shall be given in each state to the
public acts records and judicial
proceedings of every other state
so what does full faith and credit
actually mean it's designed to make in a
certain sense all of the states of the
united states part of a single system
and so full faith and credit means that
a court judgment for example in one
state will be recognized in every state
so if you have a valid judgment in new
york for example and you move to
california the california courts are
required to give effect to that judgment
to that state court judgment
so long as it was validly issued there
was a federal statute
known as the defense of marriage act or
doma
that was passed under president clinton
and recently the supreme court struck
that down as
unconstitutional so now under full faith
and credit if you're married in one
state you're married in another state as
well you can see the kinds of problems
that would exist if if states didn't
honor
the legal decisions that were made by
other states such as who's married or
who's divorced or who owns a particular
piece of property or whether
a particular child is going to be in the
custody of one parent rather than
another
and the full faith and credit clause is
designed to say in order for
our system to work as a unified whole
while it's true that the courts of
georgia are distinct from the courts of
new york etc they're separate systems
but they have to treat the work that eat
that each other does with respect
if we
move on to section two this
says that the citizens of each state
shall be entitled to all
privileges and immunities of citizens in
the several states so what are these
privileges and immunities
so the privileges and immunities clauses
has been one that's subject uh to a
number of uh sort of debate uh in the
courts uh in the academic literature uh
but basically privileges and immunities
have been construed to be those sorts of
things uh that would go with citizenship
so the right to travel for example
is a privilege and immunity those sorts
of things
occasionally in american history there
have been moments where
states didn't want to let citizens of
other states come through
so during the the depression there was
an effort by some states to limit the
the migration of people from out of
state to in-state and the supreme court
said that's not permissible it also
protects the right to travel in 1999 the
supreme court dealt with a case called
signs versus roe
and what that case was about is that
california had relatively generous
welfare benefits
and california wanted to uh set up its
law in such a way that it wouldn't
encourage people from other states to
move to california just to get the
welfare benefits so what they did is
they said that if you don't live in
california if you're moving from out of
state and you apply for welfare benefits
then we're going to give you the welfare
benefits that you would have gotten in
your state for the first year we're not
going to give you the higher california
benefits we're going to give you
whatever you would have gotten
where you came from that's
unconstitutional and the supreme court
said that violates the privileges and
communities clause we're one country one
nation
people are allowed to cross the borders
whenever they want
interesting but there's this second part
of it that says no person held to
service or labor in one state under the
laws thereof escaping into another shall
in consequence of any law or regulation
therein be discharged from service or
labor so what is that all about so that
is one of the most unfortunate probably
the most unfortunate clauses in our
constitution it's known as the fugitive
slave clause and that title is is pretty
descriptive so if you
have a slave who is validly
owned as it were in those days under one
state's law and that person escaped to a
free state uh this clause gave the owner
the right uh to reclaim uh and that
slave and put them back uh into sort of
ownership in their own state it is a
sneaky way of talking about slavery and
this compromise with slavery was
necessary to create the united states
slavery the word isn't used in the
constitution
they only use these euphemisms these
sort of complicated circumlocutions
and there's an argument that there's a
reason for that and the reason for that
is that a lot of the framers of the
constitution didn't support slavery
opposed slavery they did think that it
was important to have a united states
and to have a constitution
so they wanted to
to do what was necessary to achieve that
but they did the absolute minimum and
they did it in such a way
that consciously doesn't
recognize and legitimize the institution
of slavery all right so
then we get into
new states and territories
so i think it was very forward-looking
of the framers to recognize that new
states might want to join the union and
then to provide a process for that so
can you tell us a little bit about what
that process was like so article 4
section 3 clause 1 provides the process
for admitting new states
again it recognizes that new states
might want to join the union and it
gives a wide latitude to congress for
admitting new states so so basically the
process was uh that a territory would
indicate the congress that it wished to
become a state uh then they would submit
a constitution uh and congress would
approve the new state uh but the
constitution itself and article four
places some limitations on that um some
of the eastern states were concerned
that the large western territories might
become too influential uh so they had a
couple of provisions that no new state
could be created out of an old state
nor could parts of states be combined
to form a new state unless there was
consent from all of the involved states
and it's it's not so clear that that
purchase
of territory from foreign governments
was a power that was granted in the
constitution to anyone thomas jefferson
who was the president at the time of the
louisiana purchase had doubts that the
louisiana purchase was constitutional he
thought that it was a great idea to
purchase all that land from france
but he thought that it would require a
constitutional amendment
for the united states to have that power
this is different from texas joining the
union but
uh the house and the senate didn't have
the same qualms that
president jefferson did
and so they agreed to
approve the louisiana purchase and to
fund it when the bill got to thomas
jefferson's desk he signed it moving on
to section four there's this promise
here that the federal government will
guarantee every state a republican form
of government and shall protect each of
them against invasion or domestic
violence what does this mean
so we see here an article for the end of
article 4 a really sort of famous and
important promise to each of the
individual states the federal government
is promising to basically aid them in
keeping a republican form of government
as we'll remember benjamin franklin
famously said we've given you a republic
if you can keep it
so when we talk about invasion when
section 4 talks about invasion it's
pretty clear that what they're talking
about is invasion by some hostile state
and of course during this period there
was continuing conflict with england and
the idea is that if new york or
south carolina gets
invaded by england that's not just that
particular state's problem it's the
nation's problem and the national
government has an obligation
to protect against invasion and i
imagine it also prevents someone from
for example declaring themselves the
king of maryland the republican form of
government clause does that
it it leaves the details to the states
but the basic idea is that there has to
the the the concept of republican
government that's embodied in article
four is majority rule that even if there
were free and fair elections
the state could not choose to have
military or hereditary government so
even if everybody in california got
together and said you know what we
really need is a good family that
that generation after generation will
lead us and they will be
the the kings and queens of california
and this is what we want and so we're
going to amend our constitution to
provide for hereditary
leadership in our state and we're going
to find somebody great and this is what
we want to do article 4 would say
we can't choose to do that even through
democratic means so as we've learned
article 4 requires states to give full
faith and credit to the legal
proceedings of other states and to treat
the citizens of other states as well as
they treat their own citizens it
provides a process for adding new states
into the mix and guarantees a republican
form of government to the citizens of
all the states article 4 binds the
united states together so it's not just
a collection of independent states but
rather a unified nation to learn more
about article iv visit the national
constitution center's interactive
constitution and khan academy's
resources on u.s government and politics